well on Twitter you may read former CIA
head John Brennan spouting off about the
political news of the day attacking the
president's dishonesty he says but it
turns out Brennan himself is a liar he's
been caught lying odd for a government
official last year for example Brennan
told Congress that the infamous steel
dossier had no influence at all on the
Intel community's claim that Russia
interfered in the 2016 election here's a
selection you know who commissioned the
steel dossier
I don't did the CIA rely on it no one I
because we we did it wasn't part of the
corpus of intelligence information that
we had it was not in any way used as a
basis for the intelligence community
like by the way Brandon you should know
this is an NBC and MSNBC paid
contributor now and needless to say two
top former Intel officials though
dispute his claim when you just heard
that the dossier formed no part of the
corpus of intelligence used by our
government to spy on the Trump campaign
retired National Security Agency
director Michael Rogers and former
Director of National Intelligence Jim
clapper both admit now that the steel
dossier and its Clinton campaign funded
allegations did in fact influence the
Intel community assessment we knew that
but it's nice to hear it confirmed
Molly Hemingway is senior editor at the
Federalist and she joins us tonight
Molly a lot of I don't even following
this carefully a lot of these stories
seem to lead back to this this guy John
Brennan and you would think as the
former head of the CIA
he's someone you'd be able to trust but
he seems not only a liar but an inept
one that's reading this we have a
problem with multiple heads of
intelligence agencies and that does
include Brennan who has a history of
lying specifically about spying on
American citizens so it's difficult to
hold him take him seriously but we've
also had problems with falsehoods being
said also by James clapper who gave
inconsistent testimony about his leaking
to the media and we have also had
problems with
call me himself whether he understands
what a leak is and how he has been
involved in it but one of the things
that's interesting is clapper and Comey
have been so much a part of this story
and we've seen their names a great deal
but Brennan has been able to kind of
stay out of the limelight
until recently where people are starting
to piece together just how integral he
was to the entire Russian narrative so
for instance actually please go ahead
yeah he actually launched the
investigation he's bragged about how he
was involved in launching the
investigation he also was really key in
briefing Harry Reid which Harry Reid has
said he understood that he was being
briefed by Brennan specifically so he
would leak that information and get it
out to the media and also pressure James
Comey and then you know these other
things that are interesting that are
coming out now about how he claimed that
the dossier wasn't used which made no
sense already because we know the
dossier was used to secure a wiretap
against someone in the Russia
investigation and also just you know it
just stands to reason that it would have
been included but now we actually have
people who are who do have a little bit
more integrity particularly Mike Rogers
saying that of course it was used in the
intelligence community assessment it's
becoming clear that a lot of the secrecy
surrounding these activities is designed
not to protect the United States from
foreign threats but to protect the
misdeeds of the people gathering the
intelligence
it's cya yes it does seem that that has
that has become a big part of the of the
operation whether people got in over
their head whether they were led astray
by Brennan and they did things that
maybe they shouldn't have done it does
seem that a lot of what we've seen in
the last few months is about attempting
to keep people from finding out the full
extent of what was happening today the
New York Times did report based on just
a widespread leaking from people who
were involved in the investigation that
yes people are now admitting they were
spying on the Trump campaign in a fairly
widespread fashion it wasn't just Carter
Page it was four top officials they
weren't just using FISA wiretaps they
were also using National Security
Letters and human intelligence at least
one human intelligence source so this is
this is busting wide open and I think
people will start demanding a little bit
more in terms of just what the FBI and
other intelligence agencies were
thinking when they began spying on the
political campaign of a major party
liberals used to be worried about things
like this not anymore well ahem anyway
thank you thanks for that thank you